russell wilson said his piece to dan
patrick back in february
his agent said his piece
specifically russell wilson wants to
stay with the seahawks but if he were to
be traded he would accept trade to the
bears saints raiders and cowboys we
haven't heard anything more since then
it's died down pete carroll called it
old news last week appearing with rich
eisen but i still think it's something
to keep an eye on because as of
wednesday june 2 the cap charge for
trading russell wilson plummets from 39
million to 13 million
and you can't rule out the possibility
in my view because we've seen these
crazy trades come out of nowhere before
where everyone's kept their mouths shut
until it happens i can't rule out the
possibility that someone is waiting and
lurking and ready to make the seahawks
an offer they won't refuse for russell
wilson come june 2. i'm not saying it's
going to happen i would bet against it
but i can't say it's an impossibility
mike there's two teams out there that
interest me right now about their future
quarterback plans
for a couple of reasons and i'll tell
you my two teams one is the carolina
panthers david tepper being the wild
card owner he's made it very clear
temper reminds me of what uh stephen
ross was like
over the last five six seven years and
that is
we are going to move heaven and earth
and do whatever it takes
to get our quarterback of the future you
know they thought they might have had
him with ryan tanhill they didn't and so
then they moved heaven and earth they
took to otangovaloa after failing to be
able to trade up to get joe burrow
so
so you know how aggressive an owner can
be inside an organization to push push
push now you go to the carolina panthers
david tepper has proven that he's
exactly that same way you overpay for
teddy bridgewater one year and then the
next year we're getting rid of teddy
bridgewater we'll take the cap
consequences of it and then after that
you sign sam darn or you trade for sam
darnold
and
you you kind of trade for him but in a
very tepid way he's your guy you don't
guarantee that he's your guy by trading
a two a four and a six forum
but i do think
that that is one team that if a
quarterback opens up in the middle of
this year the carolina panthers would be
very aggressive to try to go get him the
other team is the philadelphia eagles i
don't see the eagles doing something
before giving jalen hurts a shot this
year especially because
the eagles are what i would call
in a classic kind of rebuilding
retooling year
and they sit there with three probably
three number ones next year and i've
always viewed this
as
the philadelphia eagles are going to see
how jalen hurts does and if he pulls a
dak prescott and shocks the world as
prescott did in 2016
uh not even allowing tony romo the
ability to get his job back when he was
healthy
if jalen hurts plays at a very high
level
throws for 4 300 yards the eagles win 11
games well he's going to be their
quarterback next year
but
most of us feel that that probably isn't
going to happen
now
both of those teams
i think are going to be very active in
the quarterback market
starting next february
but you never know based on their recent
histories
and the aggressiveness
of their uh in one case an owner we
don't really know scott federer's
uh you know ethos yet about how
aggressive he'd be he's the new carolina
gm but we know about howie roseman and
he never met a trade he didn't like
so those are the two teams i would watch
out for but i agree with you i russell
wilson i think is the the far bigger
likelihood that he quarterbacks the
seattle seahawks this year and then
after the year we see where they are
and and if the seahawks have resigned
themselves to the reality that at some
point russell wilson is going to have
the next phase of his career with a new
team and he's not going to sign another
contract they're not going to want to
sign him to another contract because
he's going to want 50 million a year and
they don't view him as that kind of guy
that's always going to be top of the
market top of the market top of the
market
the door is open for someone i believe
to get their attention now if they can
trade back a quarterback that helps the
seahawks get through this year and maybe
another year that's the key peter and
look we don't know whether or not
russell wilson would welcome a trade to
the panthers or the eagles he's got that
no trade clause i think that his agent
mark rogers was holding some teams in
his back pocket when he identified four
but the raiders are still out there and
i know they're saying all the right
things about derek carr
but
if you're john gruden
how do you not at least ponder the
possibilities
some morning when you're in your office
at 3 50. five minutes after you get
there you made your cup of coffee you're
thinking about derek carr you're
thinking about russell wilson
what if you throw a package together
with derek carr plus whatever else it
would take i i just
i just can't say it's impossible at this
point because the the window's there
it's cracked slightly still
and if i'm john gruden i'm thinking this
may be my only chance to get this guy
because next year there's going to be
others who are hovering maybe this is
the time we do the the big thing the big
move the dramatic thing that takes this
franchise to a new level
i mean maybe
i i just think
at this point there's so many other fish
to fry
in that organization
there's so many other things that you
really need a lot more than quarterback
and i understand
i i've always said this that john
gruden's favorite quarterback is the one
he doesn't have
and you know so i get the fact that he
might look at russell wilson and say oh
my god imagine how great we would be if
we had him
i i just i don't see them moving heaven
and earth to get russell wilson now who
knows probably you know they'll trade
for him next week i i think the much
more likely candidates
at some point
uh would be number one uh carolina and
again look
maybe a number two philly
but maybe maybe underline this that you
know if john schneider does decide to
move him he's gonna move him to an afc
team because he doesn't want to face him
every year or or you know more often
clearly but you know we'll see i i just
think it's at this point i think it's
highly unlikely he moves this year
hey and plenty of people are still
saying watch miami as a desean watson
destination if they would be in play for
deshaun watson why would they not at
least kick the tires on russell wilson
again we don't know that he'd want to go
to miami but if he did you could make
the argument that russell wilson would
be the better fit the better long-term
quarterback for the dolphins than
deshawn watson would be and and and
again
it's just we can't
shut doors and say that's never going to
happen that's never going to happen the
nfl is too crazy for us to foreclose
those possibilities and we've seen these
things occur
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports